I mean I don't mind I'll take a fine I
don't really care I thought you know
um Ben Taylor was [__] terrible
tonight
um I thought that on most nights you
know a couple other you know out of the
three there's one or two that just
[__] the game up you know and it's
it's been like that a couple couple
games in a row um Denver was tough
obviously you come out tonight you're
competing pretty hard at third quarter I
get a [__] Tech changes the whole
dynamic of the game changed the whole
flow of the game and um you know most of
the rest are trying hard I like a lot of
the wrestler trying hard they're pretty
fair they communicate well and then you
got the other ones who just want to be
dicks and um just kind of [__] the game
up nobody's coming to see that [__] they
come to see the players and um I think
we're losing a little bit of the fabric
of what the NBA is and was and
um it's been disappointing this season
um you can look up most of my texts this
year I've been with Ben Taylor
officiating so at a certain point as a
player you feel it's personal and um
it's never a good place to be that's not
why we lost tonight we got all played
um but it definitely makes it tougher to
overcome